there is
a crisis here
millions of people have fled venezuela
as the country
[Music]
crumbles
many of them are coming over this border
into colombia
in this border town of kukuta you see
people with
suitcases full of all their belongings
they don't know where they're going they
just know they need to get out of their
country
if you need proof of how bad it is in
venezuela right now
look at this purse this purse is made
entirely of
the bills of the venezuelan currency the
bolivares inflation is so high
that this money is now completely
worthless and so my friend jorge over
here
has gathered a ton of this stuff and
turned it into commodities it diverses
into sculptures it is worse than it
sounds and it sounds pretty bad
the country's inflation rate will rise
to one
million percent
more than a million venezuelans have
moved into colombia in recent years
and in an era of record-setting
migration when borders seem to be
getting thicker
harder to cross colombia is doing
something that you don't see very often
it's opening its doors and it's letting
people in
the border crisis a shock it's a real
humanitarian crisis
the economic crisis there is about to
get even worse
is there a point at which colombia and
other countries in latin america step in
and say enough is enough now
[Music]
this border town of cucuta is now
totally bustling
this is the very end of the border right
as people are entering so the one thing
that you'll hear
that is a little interesting is
we buy hair
to continue on their way to make some
money is the women will sell their hair
basically get 100 000 pesos which is
like 30
[Music]
i'm eating a venezuelan style hot dog
[Music]
and the guys are reflecting on how much
this hot dog would cost
if they were trying to buy it in
venezuela with the current economic
situation
[Music]
87 of the country's households into
poverty
images that we have just never seen in
latin america before is unfortunately
something we're seeing now
the collapse of venezuela didn't happen
because of a civil war or a natural
disaster
but rather the colossal economic
mismanagement by the country's leader
nicolas maduro
in just a few years maduro grabbed
control of most of the government
and then drove the country into an
economic disaster worse than the great
depression
and the fall of the soviet union
[Music]
of the two million people who have left
venezuela in the midst of this crisis
about a million have come to colombia
easily more than any other country
the response by most countries in the
region has been to put up new measures
to stop migrants from flooding into
their country
but not colombia here the border stays
relatively easy to cross
and even though colombia already has
millions of its own people in need of
humanitarian assistance
the colombian people and politicians
continue to let these migrants in
so i have decided that we're not going
to close the border we have to give them
support
now we're in the refugee camp is that
they're calling it and here the
government provides all sorts of
services
to these people
haircuts and manicures
today in the camp they're playing music
some colombians some venezuelan
and everyone locals migrants start
singing and clapping
[Music]
along
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
the colombian government has given most
of these migrants status
allowing them to live in the country get
health care work and study for two years
but it's not just the colombian
government opening its doors
in a neighborhood near the border people
have started taking migrants into their
homes
indefinitely and for free
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and to understand why these people are
opening up their doors to venezuelans
you have to understand their past
if you go back to the 1800s colombia and
venezuela were actually a part of the
same country
called gran colombia this country
eventually broke up into the modern
states we know today
decades later in the 80s and 90s
colombia was experiencing some of the
worst violence in its
decades-long war with the rebel group
called the farc
this war displaced more than 7 million
people
more than any other modern war hundreds
of thousands of those people fled to
venezuela where the economy was thriving
and the venezuelans took the men
[Music]
so in a sense this is the colombian's
way of paying back the venezuelans for
the hospitality they were given
here at the border you go down the
street a little bit and you see this
sign that says welcome to colombia
above it it says colombia and venezuela
united forever in spite of these two
countries being different having very
different governments
there is this common identity among the
people
[Music]
but there are reasons to believe that
this sense of solidarity
might not last forever a slew of crimes
allegedly committed by venezuelans
have led to a new wave of skepticism in
the country
earlier this year the police chief in
this border town told people that they
shouldn't rent their properties to
venezuelans after a migrant was arrested
for a homicide
but despite the growing skepticism many
venezuelans continue to see tremendous
support in colombia
a country that has chosen to keep its
doors open to the thousands of migrants
who come in every day
i'm so glad you've watched episode 1 of
borders columbia i've got a bunch more
episodes coming your way
another one next week so keep watching
and i want to say a huge thank you to
the borders local network
they allow me an outsider to come into
this place and understand it in a better
way
so thank you to the locals who
contributed and stay tuned for more
borders